♪ ♪
'S >> Bret: SOLEMN SPOT HERE
AT THE NIXON LIBRARY, THE
RESTING PLACE FOR
PRESIDENT NIXON.
THERE HAVE BEEN TWO NEW SMALL
EXPLOSIVE ERUPTIONS AT THE
SUMMIT OF KILAUEA VOLCANO ON
HAWAII'S BIG ISLAND.
SCIENTISTS REPORT NEAR
CONTINUOUS LOW LEVEL ASH
EMISSIONS AND DANGERS FROM THAT
ON THE LAVA, BEHIND A NEW PUSH
FOR EVACUATIONS.
JEFF PAUL IS IN HAWAII TONIGHT.
>> I CAN'T BE ANYMORE FRANK.
IT'S TIME TO GET OUT.
IT IS PROBABLY PAST TIME TO GET
OUT.
>> DIRE WARNING FOR SOME
RESIDENTS ON THE EASTERN SIDE
HAWAII'S BIG ISLAND, AS LAVA
FLOWS ARE MOVING FASTER COME
ACROSS ONE MAJOR ROADWAY AND
THREATENING OTHERS.
>> THE COUNTY IS DOING
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO GET THE
LAST FEW HOLDOUTS IN THAT AREA
EVACUATED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
EVACUATED AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBL
POSSIBLE.
THE SITUATION COULD TURN
PRECARIOUS REALLY FAST.
>> NOT TOO LONG AGO, YOU COULD
DRIVE DOWN THIS HIGHLY BUT YOU
CAN SEE IT'S COVERED WITH LAVA
THAT IS STILL HOT AND PUTTING
OUT FLAMES.
IF YOU WERE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THIS PILE OF LAVA, YOU WOULD
NEED AN EARLY LEFT.
THERE ARE GROWING CONCERNS LAVA
COULD SOON REACH A NEARBY
GEOTHERMAL PLANT.
IT HAS SEEPED ONTO THE EDGE OF
THE PROPERTY, SPARKING FEARS OF
A POSSIBLE EXPLOSION AND RELEASE
OF TOXIC STEAM.
THE PLANT IS FAR FROM THE
SUMMIT, BUT IT'S CLOSE TO AN
ACTIVE FEATURE IN THE RIFT ZONE.
CREWS HAVE REMOVED
50,000 GALLONS OF FLAMMABLE
LIQUID AND ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
QUENCHING THE WELLS WITH COLD
WATER.
>> IT'S NOT EASY TO PREDICT
WHERE IT'S GOING TO GO AND WHEN
IT'S GOING TO GET THERE.
>> LAVA HAYES IS A FACTOR.
LAVA IS HITTING THE OCEAN,
CREATING CORROSIVE PLUMES THAT
CONTAIN ACID AND TINY PIECES OF
GLASS.
RESIDENTS SAYING WHAT IS SCARING
THE MOST, NOT KNOWING WHAT'S
NEXT.
>> THIS YO-YO EFFECT OF BAD, BAD
AND THEN IT'S BETTER.
WE ARE ROLLING WITH THE PUNCHES
BUT YOU NEVER KNOW WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
>> HAWAII NATIONAL GUARD IS
PREPPING ITS FLEET OF
HELICOPTERS FOR RESCUE MISSIONS
IN THE EVENT PEOPLE BECOME
STRANDED.
GUARD MEMBERS ARE ON STANDBY, AS
LAVA FLOWS INCREASE IN SPEED AND